THE REAL DEAL.
>> Greg: IT TOOK A WHILE BUT
FINALLY PROGRESS.
SINCE THE MUELLER REPORT SAID NO
COLLUSION, WE ARE NOW SEEING THE
MOST VEHEMENT ANTI-TRUMP-ERS
RECONSIDER THEIR HORN EXTREMISM.
CHELSEA HAVE ARE, SHE VICIOUSLY
ATTACKED THE TRUMP FAMILY, THEIR
SUPPORTERS AND ANYONE CONNECTED.
IT WASN'T NORMAL BUT SHE
COULDN'T SEE IT UNTIL NOW ON
BILL MAHER.
>> I HAD NEVER HAD MY WORLD FEEL
SO UNHINGED.
I HAD TO PAY A PSYCHIATRIST TO
LISTEN TO ME [BLEEP]
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP FOR ABOUT THE
FIRST THREE WEEKS AND THEN ONCE
WE GOT PAST THAT AND WE GOT TO
THE REAL STUFF, I REALIZE THE
PARALLEL THERE WAS MY WORLD
BECOMING UNHINGED WHEN I WAS A
LITTLE GIRL.
MY BROTHER DIED WHEN I WAS
9 YEARS OLD.
I'D NEVER RELATED THE TWO BUT
FOR ME, AND I CAN IMAGINE IT
MUST BEEN FOR SO MANY PEOPLE, A
HUGE EMOTIONAL TRIGGER OF
EVERYTHING BEING DESTABILIZED.
I REALIZED JUST HOW SPOILED AND
PRIVILEGED I'D BEEN ALL MY LIFE
TO REALIZE, TO BE THIS UPSET AND
ON A 10 EVERY DAY AND THE
OUTRAGE AND ANGER, I JUST WANTED
TO [BLEEP]
FIGHT PEOPLE.
>> Greg: THIS IS GOOD.
TO BE ABLE TO STEP BACK AND SEE
THAT YOUR REACTION IS LESS ABOUT
THE WORLD AND MORE ABOUT THE
STUFF THAT'S INSIDE YOU.
EVEN BETTER, THESE ADMISSIONS
SEEM TO BE SPREADING.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY POINTS OUT
THAT.
PEREIRA -- THE CONFESSIONS ARE N
PEREIRA -- THE CONFESSIONS ARE T
PEREIRA -- THE CONFESSIONS ARE O
PEREIRA -- THE CONFESSIONS ARE B
PEREIRA -- THE CONFESSIONS ARE E
PEREIRA -- THE CONFESSIONS ARE M
PEREIRA -- THE CONFESSIONS ARE C
PEREIRA -- THE CONFESSIONS ARE E
PEREIRA -- THE CONFESSIONS ARE D
BUT THEY SHOULD BE
APPLAUDED.
PEOPLE ARE ADMITTING THEIR
BEHAVIOR WASN'T -- IT WAS NEVER
ABOUT TRUMP.
IT WAS SIMPLY TRAUMA.
I WENT THROUGH SIMILAR STUFF.
STEPPING BACK ALLOWS ONE TO SEE
THAT TAKING POLITICS TO
PERSONALLY CLOUD YOUR THINKING.
SUDDENLY EVERYONE IS RACIST OR
EVERYONE IS SEXIST OR EVERYONE
IS COLLUDING BUT FOR YOU AT
HOME, THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM
BECAUSE THE PERSONAL ISN'T
POLITICAL, MEANING POLITICS IS
JUST ONE STORE IN THE STRIP MALL
OF LIFE SO WHEN THAT STORE
CLOSES YOU HAVE OTHER STORES TO
GO TO.
FAMILY, HOBBIES, THE OUTSIDE
WORLD.
THAT IS LIFE.
BUT IF POLITICS IS PERSONAL,
THEN LIFE IS LIKE JANGO.
PULL OUT POLITICS AND IT CAN ALL
COME TUMBLING DOWN.
PEOPLE LIKE CHELSEA ARE PUTTING
THEIR LIVES BACK TOGETHER AGAIN.
WE SHOULD WISH THEM WELL.
I THINK SHE SHOULD BE APPLAUDED
FOR HER HONESTY DEFINITELY.
>> Dana: EVERYONE IS GOING
THROUGH SOMETHING.
EVERYONE YOU SEE, THEY HAVE
SOMETHING GOING ON.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT YOU'RE
GOING THROUGH.
REMEMBER, WE SAY POLITICS IS NOT
WHO YOU ARE.
YOU MIGHT BE WHAT YOU TALK ABOUT
AND WHAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
BUT POLITICS IS NOT WHO YOU ARE.
>> Greg: JUAN, WE HAVE THESE
POLITICAL FIGHTS ALL THE TIME
BUT YOU HAVE OTHER THINGS THAT
YOU DEAL WITH.
YOU HAVE KIDS, GRANDKIDS, YOU
LOVE BASEBALL.
ISN'T THAT THE HEALTHY WAY TO
DEAL WITH LIFE?
>> Juan: ABSOLUTELY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT CHELSEA
HANDLER IS THAT FUNNY.
YOU BE THE JUDGE.
I WONDER HOW SERIOUS SHE IS
ABOUT ALL THIS, CONNECTING
THINGS.
I DO THINK YOU'RE RIGHT THAT
THERE ARE LOTS OF PEOPLE WHO
WERE TRAUMATIZED BY 2016.
>> Greg: JESSE, YOU WEREN'T.
>> Jesse: ONE OF THE GREATEST
DAYS OF MY LIFE.
2024 IS GOING TO BE TOUGH.
I WOULD BLAME THE MEDIA FOR THE
TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME
BECAUSE THEY DID NOT PREPARE
DEMOCRATS FOR THE POSSIBILITY OF
THIS ELECTION AND THEN THEY
HALTED THE HEALING PROCESS BY
SAYING HE WAS AN IMPOSTER AND
HACKED THE ELECTION WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
THEN THE MEDIA COVERAGE,
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
THERE'S BEEN CHAOS AND
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN
UNPRECEDENTED.
I THINK EVERYBODY SHOULD LISTEN
TO THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE SAYS
SIT BACK AND ENJOY THE RIDE.
>> Greg: 'S TO PEOPLE THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE THAT ARE -- LIKE
JENNIFER RUBIN, NEVER FULLY
RECOVERED.
>> Katie: MAY BE SHE SHOULD
TAKE SOME ADVICE FROM CHELSEA
HANDLER AND SEE A PSYCHIATRIST.
I THINK POLITICS CAN BE
PERSONAL.
YOUR VALUES, YOUR BELIEFS BUT
YOU HAVE TO KEEP THINGS IN
PERSPECTIVE.
POLITICS IS NOT EVERYTHING.
YOU SHOULD GO OUT, GET OFF
TWITTER, ENJOY LIFE THAT THINGS
ARE GOING TO BE THERE AT THE END
OF THE DAY FOR YOU.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE POLITICAL
PARTIES.
PILATES.
>> Dana: AT THE END OF THE
DAY, I HAVE PILATES.